wir leben in einem der schönsten und
auch wohlhabendsten länder der welt
trotzdem macht sich unzufriedenheit
unter den bürgern breit das sagt
meingast friedrich merz den ich sehr
herzlich begrüße sie machen sich sorgen
um demokratie und marktwirtschaft warum
er uns ja also in der tat zunächst
einmal stimmt glaube ich der befund wir
leben ja nun wirklich in einem der
privilegierten länder dieser welt ich
denke dass so häufig was hat unsere
generation die die nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg geboren sind aufgewachsen sind
doch für ein unglaubliches glück gehabt
trotzdem ist wahr dass die
unzufriedenheit in der bevölkerung
steigt das hat viele ursachen die
unsicherheiten nehmen zu man erkennt den
weg nicht mehr auf dem sich das land
befindet und in die richtung in die sich
bewegt es gibt verteilungsdiskussion es
gibt massive umweltpolitischen
herausforderungen und ja ich würde so
weit gehen zu sagen die politik gibt
vielleicht auch nicht mehr die
ausreichenden antworten die diese
sicherheit zurückgeben in die
bevölkerung ist das vielleicht auch ein
systemproblem haben wir jetzt im
augenblick nicht auch eine kapitalismus
diskussion die zeigt dass wir fehler in
diesem system haben die offenbar nicht
behoben werden können so schnell wie
umfragen zeigen dass jedenfalls die zahl
der menschen die in deutschland auf die
frage glauben sie dass demokratie und
marktwirtschaft die probleme der
gegenwart und der zukunft lösen
glauben sie dass die zahl nimmt ab und
zwar im westen wie im osten und im osten
ist die zahl ohnehin schon immer sehr
niedrig gewesen also es gibt eine weit
verbreitete skepsis an unserer
demokratie auch an ihren
erscheinungsformen
es gibt aber auch eine zunehmende kritik
an unserer marktwirtschaftlichen ordnung
und darüber muss sich die gesellschaft
muss ich aber auch die politik gedanken
machen wenn ich ihre äußerungen jetzt so
höre dann höre ich zwar auch einen
politischen bürger aber ich höre auch
ein politiker wieder raus wie weit sind
sie im augenblick in der politik
gar nicht sagen sie ja das ist so ich
habe kein politisches amt um kein
politisches mandat ich sage immer ich
bin ein politisch interessanten
interessierter bürger ich bin auch ein
politisch besorgter bürger dieses landes
ich engagiere mich ehrenamtlich ich bin
zehn jahre vorsitzender der atlantik
brücke gewesen einer der
traditionsreichsten wenn ich die
traditionsreichste deutsche
amerikanische institution
ich bin bereit gewesen auch im
wirtschaftsrat der cdu das ist aber
keine organisation der cdu sondern eine
unternehmervereinigung die der cdu nahe
steht ein amt zu übernehmen aber ich bin
ansonsten normal in meinem beruf und bin
im praktischen und täglichen leben
unterwegs jetzt haben viele gedacht da
kommt friedrich merz wieder in die
politik gehen wir doch mal sehen aber
das hinkriegt dann haben sie auf der
allerletzten runde verloren gegen a k k
wie man so schön sagt und dann haben
alle gesagt so jetzt hier sich wieder
zurück aber wir hören ständig was von
ihm sie äußern sich zu bestimmten
umständen und missständen die sie
anprangern
da ist aber doch mehr als nur ich äußere
mich als friedrich merz als bürger nein
ich habe in der tat die abstimmung auf
dem hamburger parteitag verloren knapp
verloren aber eben verloren hat das weh
getan
naja ich hätte natürlich gerne gewonnen
ist ja völlig klar aber ich habe dann
auf dem parteitag etwas gesagt was ich
nicht nur so aus der laune des
augenblicks heraus gesagt habe sondern
ich habe es so gemeint und so
praktiziere ich jetzt auch ich habe der
neuen parteivorsitzenden der cdu
angeboten zu helfen
ich habe der partei angeboten ihr zu
helfen bei den themen die jetzt vor uns
liegen und dafür braucht man kein
politisches amt dafür braucht man kein
politisches mandat ich bringe mit den
themen und den meinungen die ich habe in
diese politische diskussion ein
und das tue ich gerne aber das heißt
nicht dass damit jetzt frustration oder
enttäuschung verbunden
ich habe diese rolle angenommen aber es
könnte auch ambitionen heißen denn wenn
wir uns anschauen
manche sagen sie ist entzaubert hkk nach
den letzten wochen nach dem letzten
monaten da ist ja möglicherweise ein
spielraum und während sie nicht
interessiert in diesem spiel raum
ranzugehen also zunächst einmal wir
haben alle personellen entscheidungen
die getroffen werden mussten getroffen
in der cdu es gibt einen neuen vorstand
an das präsidium eine neue
parteivorsitzende und die hat jetzt
unsere gemeinsame unterstützung und
hilfe verdient die leiste ich und alles
was dann möglicherweise jetzt oder
später kommt muss dann entschieden
werden aber ich mache ganz ehrlich
überhaupt keine gedanken über diese
frage entscheidend ist dass wir in der
situation in der wir heute in diesem
land sind die themen aufarbeiten die
aufgearbeitet werden müssen damit die
politik ihre glaubwürdigkeit zurück
bekommt da ist ein punkt den sie zuletzt
angeprangert haben ein großer frust bei
der polizei und bei den soldaten die
fühlen sich sagen sie nicht mehr so
richtig unterstützt da gibt es rechte
tendenzen
da macht sich auch der innenminister
seehofer sorgen
was ist da für frust und wie gefährlich
ist der ich würde gerne deutlich
unterscheiden zwischen denen die da wie
sie sagen mit rechten tendenzen oder
rechtsradikalen ansichten aus der
polizei aus der bundeswehr heraus
versuchen stimmung zu machen das ist ein
ganz ganz kleiner verschwindend kleiner
teil ernst zu nehmen aber nicht
repräsentativ für bundeswehr und polizei
was ich gesagt habe am letzten
wochenende war und dabei bleibe ich wir
haben es mit einem verlust an
wählerinnen und wählern zu tun die für
die spd und auch die union gewählt haben
und die heute zur afd gehen und das gilt
auch für polizeibeamte
das gilt für soldatinnen und soldaten
die jetzt bei der afd
ihre politische heimat sehen und nicht
mehr bei union und spd so und das ist
ein ernst zu nehmendes problem
ich will ihnen ein beispiel sagen was
mir gerade in diesen tagen in berlin
berichtet worden ist da ist ein
generalstabsoffizier aus der bundeswehr
gebeten worden in die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion als
wissenschaftlicher mitarbeiter für eine
bestimmte zeit zu gehen das ist ein
normales verfahren wie das immer wieder
auch aus anderen ministerien praktiziert
wird
der hat gesagt nein vielen dank ich habe
ein angebot von der afg fraktion und ist
jetzt wissenschaftlicher mitarbeiter bei
der afg fraktion und ich sag mal wenn es
solche beispiele schon ganz oben gibt im
generalstab also general schafft
offizieren der bundeswehr dann muss muss
sich die führung der bundeswehr fragen
was läuft da eigentlich schief aber die
rechtsextremen tendenzen das müssen wir
jetzt auch noch mal sauber unterscheiden
dies offenbar bei polizei und soldaten
vermehrt gibt sind dass frustration
tendenzen sind das sind das auf wie
gelungen ist das motiviert durch
bestimmte dinge
ich würde mal zunächst unterstreichen
dass die ganz große mehrzahl der polizei
beamten und beamtinnen und die ganz ganz
große mehrzahl der soldatinnen und
soldaten treu zu diesem land zu diesem
staat stehen und ihre arbeit ihr machen
und dann deren verhalten gibt es nichts
zu kritisieren im gegensatz teil die
haben unsere wirklich volle
unterstützung verdient es gibt einen
kleinen teil in beiden
sicherheitsinstitutionen bei der
bundeswehr wie bei der polizei die immer
wieder mal auch aufgefallen sind
das ist leider so dass war übrigens
früher auch schon so das ist nichts
neues das ist nicht sehr erfreulich das
ist zum teil unappetitlich dagegen muss
man vorgehen
aber ich würde noch einmal gerne
sorgfältig unterscheiden zwischen denen
die mit einer demokratischen
grundüberzeugung sagen wir fühlen uns
bei den herkömmlichen parteien nicht
mehr ausreichend vertreten und denen die
jetzt ins rechtsextremistische abgleiten
und deren handlungen und deren taten
völlig unter
welche konsequenzen hätte es neben den
furchtbaren mord an walter lübke
das ist möglicherweise eine art von
netzwerk gibt zumindest mehrere die
daran beteiligt sind wie gefährlich ist
das was da stattgefunden hat also mich
hat dieser mordanschlag zutiefst
erschüttert ich habe walter lübke
gekannt noch aus einer zeit wo er im
hessischen landtag abgeordneter war und
kassel ist ja in der unmittelbaren
nachbarschaft praktisch für meinem alten
bundestagswahlkreis wenn sich
herausstellen sollte dass das mehr war
als nur in anführungsstrichen die tat
eines einzeltäters
dann bekommt die ganze sache noch einmal
eine ganz andere dimension und nach
alledem was wir bis heute wissen hat ja
mindestens in der frage der waffen
beschaffung unterstützer um mittäter
gegeben also es ist eine ganz
grauenhafte vorstellung
rechtsextremismus an sich ist ein
steigendes problem in deutschland
wie muss man damit umgehen ja es ist
sein es ist im grunde ein krebsgeschwür
dieser gesellschaft ich glaube wir
werden nicht nur die reine polizeiliche
arbeit gegen diese netzwerke verstärken
müssen wir müssen auch die
gesellschaftspolitische diskussion
führen wie kann es eigentlich zu diesem
abgleiten in den rechtsextremismus
kommen
das geht bis in den hooligan bereich im
fußball
ich bin lange zeit bei borussia dortmund
aktiv gewesen und habe dann auch immer
diese diese sogenannten fenster gesehen
die sich da auch politisch zu
radikalisieren
auch darüber müssen wir sprechen dass
wir können das auch nicht einfach weiter
hinnehmen dass mit dem hitlergruß und
mit eindeutigen tätowierungen hier die
menschen auf der straße herumlaufen das
sind straftaten und darum geht muss man
vorgehen aber noch einmal wir müssen uns
auch mit der frage beschäftigen was
bringt eigentlich junge menschen dazu
sich politisch so zu radikalisieren und
dann auch so ins abseits zu stellen
da kommen sehr schnell zwei dinge
zusammen nämlich einmal afd und einmal
rechtsextrem wie klar kann man da
unterscheiden und man kann es eben nur
mit großen schwierigkeiten und man muss
glaube ich all denjenigen die dazu afd
gehen auch als wähler oder unterstützer
sagen fast ein bisschen auf was da in
dieser partei auch passiert diese partei
lebt letztendlich auch strategisch davon
dass sie ganz rechte auch rechtsextreme
mitglieder und funktionsträger in ihren
reihen nicht nur duldet sondern fördert
diese partei grenzt sich nicht
ausreichend zum rechtsextremismus
ab und das ist ein ganz strukturelles
und grundsätzliches problem dieser afd
und das macht sie auch als kooperations
oder gar als koalitionspartner für alle
demokratischen parteien im gegenwärtigen
zustand in dem sie sich befindet und ich
sehe nicht dass sich das ändert
vollkommen inakzeptabel
also nicht eine mögliche koalition man
hat ja immer mal so ein bisschen den
eindruck
in ostdeutschland wäre es ja
möglicherweise so dass wir im herbst
einen jahr machtwechsel schon fast
bekommen könnten
wäre es da sinnvoll zu überlegen ob man
im ein oder anderen fall kooperationen
vielleicht nicht koalitionen aber
kooperationen in berg runter hat es
einen klaren beschluss gegeben der cdu
am letzten montag und den teile ich voll
und ganz hier eine ganz klare abgrenzung
vorzunehmen es kommt nicht in frage dass
auf der ebene der länder oder gar des
bundes mit dieser partei zusammen
gearbeitet oder gar eine koalition
gegangen wird nein
und dabei muss es auch bleiben trotzdem
muss man sich die frage stellen warum
kommt ist wir haben es bei der
europawahl gesehen zu zahlen
die sehr eindeutig zeigen es gibt ein
enormes west ost gefälle oder ost west
gefälle wie man das immer nun auch
beschreiben mag
vor allen dingen im hinblick auf die afd
warum ist die afg im osten so stark das
ist eine schwierig sehr schwierig zu
beantwortende frage und ich will mir da
aus westdeutscher sicht heraus kein
abschließendes urteil erlauben ich bin
in den letzten wochen ziemlich viel in
sachsen brandenburg und thüringen in
sachsen-anhalt gewesen ich versuche das
zu verstehen
ich habe es noch nicht ganz wirklich
verstanden aber es hängt natürlich auch
damit zusammen dass es dort immer noch
so das gefühl gibt zu spät gekommen zu
sein immer noch das gefühl gibt fünftes
rad am wagen zu sein immer noch das
gefühl gibt benachteiligt zu sein jetzt
auch zum beispiel durch die energiewende
teil 2 erneut benachteiligt zu werden
mit arbeitsplätzen etwa in den
braunkohle
und dieselben elf milliarden für
ausgegeben na ja gut aber ist einmal der
verlust der arbeitsplätze dort steht an
erster stelle im gefühlsleben der
menschen das kann man auch verstehen
dass es da für kompensationen gibt und
dass man dafür alles mögliche machen und
bezahlen und kaufen will ist schön und
gut aber in erster linie steht ja dort
das gefühl es geht uns erneut eine
wirtschaftliche basis in unserer heimat
verloren so und ich glaube mit dem
gefühl muss man ernsthaft umgehen und
man muss mit den menschen dort auch
sprechen und vor allem man muss zuhören
was hat das denn verfolgen wenn wir im
spätherbst wenn alle drei wahlen durch
sind in allen drei ländern komplette
machtverschiebungen haben was hat das
für die bundesrepublikanische politik
verfolgen ich kann das auch noch zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt überhaupt nicht
abschätzen wir haben am ersten september
die wahlen in brandenburg und in sachsen
dann am 27 oktober also sechs wochen
später erst in in thüringen
ich vermute mal schon die beiden ersten
landtagswahlen werden wenn sie denn so
ausgehen wie die umfragen ist im
augenblick zeigen und das muss ja nicht
zwingend der fall sein aber nehmen wir
mal an es kommt so dann wird das
erhebliche auswirkungen auf die
parteipolitische diskussion auch in
berlin haben
ich würde nur gern im augenblick dazu
ermuntern und tue es auch selbst alles
zu tun damit es nicht so weit kommt
damit dort regierungsfähige mehrheiten
ohne die afg und auch ohne die
linkspartei möglich bleiben aber sie
haben mit ihrer frage trotzdem recht es
ist eine ernst zunehmende gefährdung
auch der stabilität der politischen
mitte von den jeweiligen ländern rechts
und links wir werden sehen abgesehen
davon ist es hier auch eine frage ob
dann eine regierung die groko überhaupt
noch weiterregieren kann sie haben ja
mal die voraussage getroffen
das wird über den spätherbst oder über
dieses jahr nicht weitergehen ich bin
und bleibe dabei dass ich mir nicht
vorstellen kann dass diese koalition so
wie sie gegenwärtig arbeitet in dieser
stimmungslage über den jahreswechsel
fortbesteht
da kommen nun auch ein paar ereignisse
noch dazu neben diesen landtagswahlen
etwa der parteitag der spd im dezember
auch die erkennbaren bemühungen der spd
jetzt vorher schon die probleme zu lösen
und schon bis zum oktober möglicherweise
entscheidungen herbeizuführen ob sie
denn in der koalition bleiben
wenn ja unter welchen bedingungen also
die spannung dieser koalition sind groß
die beschäftigung mit sich selbst
absorbiert einen enormen zeitanteil und
die zeit um wirklich gut zu regieren ist
dann einfach zu kurz und man sieht sie
an den ergebnissen
sie waren fraktionschef von einer
starken fraktion und einer starken cdu
und einer starken spd als opposition
aber jetzt haben wir volksparteien die
eigentlich nur noch suchen können wo
können wir noch kooperieren oder im
zweifelsfall sogar koalieren weil sonst
bleiben wir gar nicht mehr an der macht
was ist mit den volksparteien los ich
bin im jahr 2000 fraktionsvorsitzender
geworden da waren wir gerade hier in
berlin wahr ist dass die volksparteien
die sogenannten volksparteien heute
keine mehrheit mehr hätten zusammen in
deutschland wenn es zur bundestagswahl
käme die spd deutlich unter 20 die union
deutlich unter 30 das zusammen gibt
keine mehrheit mehr
im deutschen bundestag und auch in
vielen länder parlamenten sie die lage
nicht viel besser aus ja was ist da los
mit den volksparteien können
volksparteien zur politischen mitte hin
noch bindend haben sie haben sie ihre
integrationskraft verloren
bei der spd muss man das leider wohl so
feststellen
ich sehe nicht wie die spd aus diesem
dilemma wieder herauskommen will mir
fehlt auch bei der spd eine klare
botschaft ein klares profil
aber ich warne davor zu glauben dass
dieses schicksal an der cdu/csu
vorbeigeht auch union die union aus cdu
csu braucht klares profil und sie
brauchen vor allem die den willen und
die fähigkeit auch zur politischen mitte
wieder hin zu integrieren und das gilt
natürlich auch für diejenigen die
konservativ denken die auch wollen dass
der nationalstaat nicht in irgendeiner
europäischen union aufgeht und
verschwindet die europäische union ist
enorm wichtig aber die nationalstaaten
müssen dort ihre rolle spielen und das
ist natürlich auch deutsche nationale
interessen gibt die wir wahrnehmen
müssen das alles muss eine union auch
deutlich machen wenn sie wieder zurück
gewinnen sie wollen ja wähler
zurückgewinnen und sagen 40 prozent kann
die cdu erreichen
wie soll sie das denn schaffen geholt
sie denn die leute zu werden im
augenblick von zwei seiten unter druck
gesetzt
zum einen von rechts von der afg und
anderen kann man natürlich auch von den
grünen
wir haben bei der europawahl vor sechs
wochen
1,1 millionen stimmen an die grünen im
überwiegend im westen verloren 230.000
an die afg überwiegend im osten
das heißt wir kommen von zwei seiten
unter druck und wir werden natürlich
auch die themen umwelt und
verträglichkeit mit unserer
industriegesellschaft besser beantworten
müssen nur 2000 der vergangenheit getan
haben zurzeit sind die grünen
wettbewerber nummer eins für die union
sie sind aber im zweifelsfall auch
koalitionspakt nummer eins für die union
können sie sich das gut vorstellen dass
so etwas funktioniert ja jetzt auch
schon länderregierungen in denen es
funktioniert mehr oder weniger gut
funktioniert wir müssen uns
grundsätzlich vorstellen können mit den
demokratischen parteien in der mitte
natürlich auch zu koalieren aber
zunächst einmal steht ja die frage nach
dem eigenen standort nach dem eigenen
stellenwert nach dem eigenen profil im
raum und bevor man über zusammenarbeit
oder koalition nachdenken muss man die
eigenen fragen geklärt haben würde ihn
das sehr schwer fallen mit grünen zu
koalieren weil sie jemand sind der doch
ein ausgeprägtes konservatives
konservatives profil hat der sehr klar
sagt naja also konservatismus ist mir
die grundlage meiner politischen ja da
auch meine meine grundsätzlich
freiheitliche liberale
wirtschaftspolitische überzeugung also
ich treffe
viele grüne die sich das auch vorstellen
können ich kann es mir auch vorstellen
aber bevor es denn soweit ist muss man
erst mal ein paar ganz grundsätzliche
entscheidungen für sich selbst getroffen
haben und nicht gleich den kompromiss
ist das was die grünen als hauptthema
haben nämlich die klimapolitik das
entscheidende thema was die deutschen im
augenblick bewegt es ist im augenblick
wahrscheinlich das entscheidende thema
es war wohl auch bei der europawahl in
den meisten ländern europas nicht
überall aber in den meisten ländern
europas das zentrale thema nur erst in
dem augenblick wo wir eine steigende
arbeitslosigkeit sehen möglicherweise
eine weitere finanzkrise
der euroraum in turbulenzen kommt wir
möglicherweise auch in anderen plätzen
der welt sehen dass dort die spannungen
bis hin zu einer kriegerischen
auseinandersetzung zu nehmen da wird
sich innerhalb von wenigen stunden die
perspektive der menschen gerade auch in
deutschland wieder ändern
also ich rate uns dringend dazu nicht
nur auf ein thema zu setzen das kann man
getrost in rom überlassen
die union muss in der ganzen breite der
themen aufgestellt sein aber dann
natürlich auch zu den umweltpolitischen
themen die antworten geben die
angemessen sind und diese antworten sind
nicht einfach
man kann nicht auf komplexe sachverhalte
so einfache antworten geben wie die
grünen das war wenn die sorge in der
bevölkerung so groß ist dass da ein
klimawandel stattfindet und dass er uns
bedroht und dass man etwas tun muss und
wenn offenbar die unterstützung ja auch
den freitags für feature schülern und
schülerinnen so deutlich gegenüber
gebracht wird dann muss das doch ein
thema sein was sie auch angehen müssen
und zwar haben sie gesagt 20.30 muss es
so eine art von agenda 20.30 geben
ökologie und ökonomie zusammenbringen
das ist glaube ich eine quadratur des
kreises oder geht das so dass ich
überhaupt nicht so im gegenteil ich
glaube das ist die eigentliche aufgabe
nämlich die ökonomischen notwendigkeiten
mit den ökologischen herausforderungen
so zu verbinden dass wir auch in zehn
jahren von heute und darüber hinaus noch
eine industrienationen eine
volkswirtschaft mit hohen
industrieanteil
sind wir werden noch unseren kindern die
frage beantworten müssen wovon sollen
sie denn in zehn jahren oder in 20
jahren in diesem land noch leben so und
das mit einer vernünftigen und guten
zielführenden umweltpolitik zu verbinden
das ist die eigentliche auch
intellektuelle herausforderung vor der
wir stehen
ich persönlich bin ganz sicher dass das
geht wir müssen dann allerdings auch
sagen wir sind für neue technologien ich
gewinnen mal ein beispiel in diesem
lande wird über die kernfusion praktisch
überhaupt nicht mehr diskutiert die
chinesen haben beschlossen spätestens im
jahr 2050 ein kernfusionsreaktor ans
netz gehen zu lassen was ist eigentlich
unsere antwort wollen wir diese
technologie dann auch den chinesen
überlassen
oder wollen wir sie hier haben eine der
umweltschonendsten besten methoden
wahrscheinlich um energie zu erzeugen
also nur mit verboten nur mit
regulierung nur mit neuen grenzwerten
nur mit einschränkungen der persönlichen
lebensführung werden wir dieses problem
weder in deutschland noch irgendwo
anders auf dieser welt lösen der
anspruch von uns muss sein
wir verbinden ökonomie ökologie mit
modernster technologie
dann heisst das aber wenn man eine
koalition mit den grünen hat dann bricht
an der grüne koalitionspartner bald weg
weil dem glaubt man das nicht mehr oder
der selbst nur manchmal gar nicht so
viel über diese ganzen koalition die
entscheidende frage ist doch vorher wer
hat das bessere angebot so und dann wird
es ein wahlergebnis geben
und da wird man im lichte dieses
wahlergebnis die entscheidung treffen
müssen wer kann denn da wir mit welchem
aufwand der basis welcher
koalitionsvereinbarung zusammen arbeiten
aber das ist doch alles eine sorge von
morgen oder übermorgen der heutige
status ist dass die politischen parteien
in deutschland programme ideen
ausarbeiten müssen um diese
herausforderung zu lösen und dann ein
wirklich überzeugendes politik angebot
machen zu müssen
die grünen versprechen jetzt 100
milliarden klimafonds bleiben der
deutschen öffentlichkeit aber die
antwort schuldig wie das eigentlich
bezahlt werden soll
sie werden in den medien hoch gesetzt ja
alle 90 sekunden verliebt sich ein
deutscher journalist in robert habeck
und stellt nicht die frage wo kommt
eigentlich das geld her dass ihr dafür
diesen klimafonds mit 100 milliarden zur
verfügung stellen dann sagen sie ja die
antwort kommt im september aber alle
anderen kriegen den vorhalt gemacht auch
in den medien ihr seid nicht auf der
höhe der zeit ihr gebt die antworten
nicht ihr bleibt sie schuldig also die
grünen sind mindestens genauso im
rückstand wie alle anderen
aber die cdu ist auch lange und die
union ist auch lange die antworten
schuldig geblieben auf eine
klimaänderung nämlich auf maßnahmen
gegen die klimaänderung da ist ja lange
zeit nicht sehr viel passiert wenn man
die zahlen sich heute an
ich würde aber gerne mit ihnen noch
einmal kurz auf zehn jahre zurückschauen
nämlich auf die atlantik brücke deren
chef sie gewesen sind
dieses deutsch amerikanische verhältnis
was sie damit ja auch ins zentrum dieser
arbeit gestellt haben das ist nicht mehr
so doll
sie haben gesagt es geht ja auch nicht
nur um eine verteidigungsfähigkeit um
pragmatismus sondern um eine
wertegemeinschaft haben sie den eindruck
dieses an wertegemeinschaft existiert
eigentlich noch in der form es wird
jedenfalls von der gegenwärtigen
regierung infrage gestellt und es war in
den letzten jahrzehnten selten einfacher
mit den amerikanern umzugehen wir haben
es im augenblick mit einer wirklich
schwierigen lage zu tun weil dort ein
präsident im amt ist er im grunde die
gesamte nachkriegsordnung und alle
institutionen die mit dieser
nachkriegsordnung verbunden sind infrage
gestellt so darüber müssen wir
nachdenken daraus konsequenzen ziehen
und ich sage auch immer wieder das möge
keiner glauben dass trump über nacht
gekommen ist und über tag wieder geht
und selbst wenn er irgendwann aus dem
amt scheidet und das kann noch sechs
jahre dauern dann werden wir feststellen
dass danach nicht wieder alles gut wird
amerika verändert sich und darauf müssen
wir antworten finden aber ist das was
wir jetzt erleben in amerika nämlich
migranten die versuchen die grenze zu
überwinden die dort ertrinken verdursten
umkommen
in flüchtlingslager kommen die grausig
sein sollen so wird jedenfalls berichtet
ist das noch der amerikanische traum das
hat jedenfalls nach meinem empfinden
nichts mit dem zu tun was die amerikaner
auch an selbstverständnis in ihrer
eigenen heimat eaton humanität immer
gelebt haben
aber das darf nicht den blick dafür
verstellen dass wir nach wie vor mit den
amerikanern in ihren grundüberzeugungen
auch in der anlage ihrer verfassung
dieselben werte teilen einer
freiheitlichen offenen liberalen
gesellschaft auch einer wirklich
funktionierenden gewaltenteilung
zwischen regierung parlament und
gerichten so und das ist das was mit und
was mit uns mit amerika unverändert
verbindet auch unabhängig von dem
gegenwärtigen regierungsmitglieder aber
wenn sie jetzt im augenblick schauen auf
die politik in der ost auf die
auseinandersetzung mit dem iran aus
ihrer sicht aus der sage mal
internationalen strategie die jedoch
offenbar nicht mehr erkennbar ist
er wächst er alt eine enorme gefahr für
einen solchen brand punkt wie gefährlich
ist das aber diese gefahr geht nicht von
amerika aus und diese gefahr geht auch
nicht von europa aus und diese gefahr
geht auch nicht vom staat israel aus
also einer ihrer kollegen hat vor
einigen wochen einmal gesagt wenn der
staat israel die waffen niederlegt ist
frieden im mittleren osten
wenn israel die waffen niederlegt ist
der staat israel nicht mehr existent ich
also das müssen wir schon genau sehen
wer da eigentlich verursacher ist für
diese spannungen und da ist der iran
einer der verantwortlichen dafür dass
die spannungen im mittleren osten in den
letzten wochen so zugenommen haben ist
das nicht donald trump der doch zündelt
und guckt wie weit er mit seiner um ja
im grunde genommen und nachvollziehbaren
strategie gehen kann
trump hat meines erachtens einen
außenpolitischen fehler gemacht mit
seinem ersten besuch in den
arabischen emiraten als sich einseitig
auf an deren seite gestellt hat und
damit auch die rolle als glaubwürdiger
vermittler im mittleren osten der
amerikaner aufgegeben hat aber die
lage-einschätzung und die einschätzung
des bedrohungspotenzial 's aus dem iran
die ist wahrscheinlich in den usa
realistischer als die auf der
europäischen seite
fassen wir noch mal zusammen sie haben
eigentlich jetzt ganz viel über
internationale und auch innenpolitische
themen gesprochen sie haben sehr viel
darüber gesagt wie sie diese situation
analysieren
das könnte man auch so ein bisschen als
bewerbungsrede an sind nein ich bin dir
gast heute abend und so haben sie mich
eingeladen und ich habe auf ihre fragen
geantwortet so wie ich das denken haben
sie oftmals sich geärgert über das was
passiert ist auch vielleicht einen
kleinen kommunikations pannen im
zusammenhang mit ihrer bewerbung bei der
cdu da ist immer wieder ihr
aufsichtsratsmandat genannt worden da
ging es um ihr einkommen da ging es um
viele andere dinge bei denen man so den
eindruck hatte vielleicht war das auch
nicht so ganz professionell kommuniziert
was sie da gemacht haben also jeder
macht fehler ich nehme mich da gar nicht
aus da ist natürlich zum teil auch
massiv gegen mich gearbeitet worden
das ist so damit
damit darauf vorbereitet dass das kommt
aber damit kann ich umgehen
haben sie das gefühl in der rolle in der
sie auch als chef beim aufsichtsrat
beiden blackrock sind sind sie eine
glaubwürdige figur die auch im
zweifelsfall auch wenn sie es jetzt im
augenblick ist mal zurückstellen
politisch jemand sind der glaubwürdig
sein kann in seiner rolle also ich hab
damit persönlich überhaupt keine
schwierigkeiten aber das muss ich
letztendlich der beurteilung derjenigen
überlassen
die mich bewerten und die mich versuchen
auch einzuschätzen
das ist ein hoch renommiertes sehr
erfolgreiches unternehmen mit einem
relativ kleinen ableger in deutschland
aber ein weltweit sehr großes
erfolgreiches unternehmen ich bin stolz
auf dieses unternehmen dort mitwirken zu
dürfen und es ist erstens hochanständig
und zum zweiten sehr erfolgreich und wir
versuchen auch einige dinge zu tun die
leg dich ja nochmal rumdrehen wir können
ja noch mal fragen werden wir sie geben
diese kommunikationspannen zu wenn wir
sehen friedrich merz hat gegen kramp
karrenbauer verloren
er sagt ich ziemlich jetzt zurück aber
ich sage natürlich was zur politik dann
können wir ja umgekehrt noch mal fragen
wenn sie jetzt so hoch gehandelt werden
wenn bei den befragungen gesagt wird
friedrich merz ist eigentlich mit habeck
auf der obersten ebene diejenigen die
wir für den kanzler uns vorstellen
können
macht ihnen das angst oder finden sie
das prima also es ist eine mischung aus
vielen gedanken die ich bei solchen
umfragen habe ja gut es ist natürlich
auch eine gewisse bestätigung auf der
anderen seite auch eine eine eine
herausforderung und zugleich auch
versuche ich das auch ein bisschen von
mir weg zu halten das wichtige ist dass
ich versuche einen beitrag dazu zu
leisten dass diese partei sauber
aufgestellt ist gut aufgestellt ist in
den themen aufgestellt ist und alles
andere kommt vielleicht später aber
darüber glauben sie es mir
was könnte ja der fall eintreten um es
wirklich jetzt abzuschließen
könnte ja der fall eintreten dass man
sagt also du oder sie je nachdem wer der
kollege oder die kollegin aus der cdu
ist du hast eigentlich die besten
chancen da ist so viel schiefgegangen
letzten wochen macht du es doch bitte
was machen sie dann wenn der tag kommen
sollte fange ich genau an dem tag an
darüber ernsthaft nachzudenken
das glauben wir ihnen jetzt mal bitte
darum ganz herzlichen dank für das
gespräch
dankeschön
[Musik]